jetzt sehen sie gerade dass die
Abgeordneten die sich mit Frauenpolitik
beschäftigen ihre Plätze Räumen und wir
haben jetzt einige Innenpolitiker die
nun hier Platz nehmen denn es geht um
waldbrandschutz und Waldbrand Bekämpfung
die
cdu/csu-fraktion und die Fraktion DIE
LINKE haben dazu jeweils einen Antrag
vorgelegt in dem sie fordern die
Kraftanstrengung für einen
waldbrandschutz noch mal zu
intensivieren die Unionsfraktion fordert
zum Beispiel
das Drohnen Video und Satellitentechnik
sowie kleinen Flugzeuge beschafft werden
um eben eine
präventiv zu erkennen und und dann auch
sie zu löschen mit löschhubschraubern
und Flugzeugen die Linksfraktion fordert
eine Luft verlegbare
brandbekämpfungseinheit die eben
bekämpfen
so und für die Unionsfraktion spricht
nun auch als erstes mechthilde Wittmann
aus der unionfraktion und Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
aus Sachsen-Anhalt Frau Staatssekretärin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stellen
Ihnen heute einen Antrag vor zur
nationalen Kraftanstrengung für einen
besseren waldbrandschutz und ich glaube
dieses ist ein Antrag der uns in Summe
hier im Haus vereint nämlich dass wir
alle wissen dass Wald eines der
ökologischen Systeme ist die für uns
jetzt am wichtigsten ist zum Klimaschutz
für das ökologische Gleichgewicht
übrigens auch für die Bewirtschaftung
und auch als großer CO2-Speicher den wir
alle umfassend hier im Land und überall
brauchen
sie wissen vielleicht dass wir in 2019
einen Rekord hatten an Waldbränden was
uns nicht gut getan hat denn sie wissen
die Vegetationszeit die der Umschlag
braucht bis so einen verbranntes Gebiet
bis so verbrannte Strecke wieder
aufgefasst werden kann kann Jahrzehnte
dauern bei Kieferwald Monokulturen die
wir uns ohnehin nicht wünschen aber bis
zu 100 Jahren meine Damen und Herren
deswegen wollen wir sie jetzt animieren
und dafür werben dass sie diesem Antrag
mit beitreten können indem wir darum
bitten dass wir die Dinge einmal kurz
betrachten wir haben eine
feuergefährdung durch den Menschen im
übrigen ist die Brandstiftung eines der
Hauptursachen dass es überhaupt zu weit
dran kommt sei sie fahrlässig oder
vorsätzlich voranlasst wir haben vorher
begünstigten Faktoren dazu gehört
Totholz todge holzte Wälder methodolz
haben unter anderem auch eine hemmende
Wirkung bei der Waldbrand Bekämpfung wir
haben vergras gewaltbestände und wir
haben durch Schädlingsbefall und das
wissen wir dass immer heftiger wird in
diesen Zeiten eine enorme Gefährdung
dafür dass diese Faktoren diese Feuer
begünstigen Faktoren entstehen
gleichzeitig haben wir
brandbekämpfungserschwerende Faktoren
das sind wie ich schon sagte der massive
todholzbestand aber auch
unzugängliche Flächen weil wir eben Wege
haben die diesen nicht zugänglich sind
weil sich unsere Feuerwehr in dem nicht
nähern können und es damit die
Bekämpfung eines Brandes die Eindämmung
wenn er denn entstanden ist umso
schwerer macht und auch hier müssen wir
dann das gleiche gilt für die
munitionsbelastung die wir übrigens
hauptsächlich hier in den Wäldern rund
um Berlin in Brandenburg immer noch
haben und insgesamt demografische
Unzulänglichkeit die ich Ihnen aus dem
alten Rand genauso schildern kann im
gebirgigen Gebirge gegen den all dieses
hat uns veranlasst heute zu sagen ich
glaube wir müssen ein bisschen mehr
zusammen helfen also nur auf die
Kommunen mit ihren freiwilligen zu
verlassen wir wissen die Freiwilligen
Feuerwehren sind eigentlich unsere
Rückgrat derzeit dazu dass wir bei der
Brandbekämpfung keine großen
Schwierigkeiten haben aber wenn der
Brand größer wird dann kommen sie nicht
näher ran als 500 Meter dann geht es um
eine andere Art von Bekämpfung dafür
brauchen wir
Flugzeuge Drohnen Drohnen zu Beobachtung
aber auch zur Bekämpfung und
entsprechende Löschhubschrauber und
meine Damen und Herren hier können wir
die Kommunen und die Länder nicht
alleine lassen hier müssen wir gemeinsam
handeln hier ist der Bund jetzt gefragt
und deswegen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
darf ich noch mal darum werben dass wir
hier gemeinsam nicht sparen bei der beim
Katastrophenschutz nicht sparen bei
unseren THW die wir dafür brauchen nicht
sparen bei der Bundeswehr die auch
national gebraucht wird so dass
insgesamt koordiniert werden kann dass
wir brandflächen schnell eindämmen
können und natürlich brauchen wir eine
entsprechende Prävention dafür bedarf
ist der Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
staatswäldern aber auch den privaten
Waldbesitzern denn sie sind auch ganz
wesentlich dass sie ihre Wälder so
schützen aber auch in ihre
Bewirtschaftung so aufstellen ich denke
da an die Beendigung der Monokulturen
und ein Aufbau der Blender
Waldwirtschaft damit diese möglichst
resilienter gegen sind das Brandt sich
ausbreiten kann und deswegen meine Damen
und Herren würde ich mich sehr freuen
wenn wir dieses gemeinsam in diesem
Hause verabschieden würden uns hier
gemeinsam zusammenraufen könnten denn
Waldbrand ist nichts was irgendwer will
und letztendlich will jeder von uns
jetzt dann ich glaube sein Adventskranz
sehen einen kleinen Weihnachtsbaum
möglich Weise ein gut duftenden aus
eigenen Wäldern haben vor allen Dingen
aber auch Erholung und Schutz in den
Wäldern suchen für uns selber auch für
die Tiere die dort leben und schließlich
unendlich für die vielfältige Natur die
sich dort ausbreitet und deswegen darf
ich Sie herzlich bitten uns im Antrag
zuzustimmen vielen
fordert im mechthilde Widmann hier in
der Debatte zum
waldbrandschutz in vier von zehn Fällen
ist übrigens die Brandursache in den
Wäldern nachweislich auf fahrlässiges
oder vorsätzliches Verhalten von
Menschen zu führen Ingo Schäfer spricht
nun für die SPD-Fraktion Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Gäste sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe den
Eindruck dass wir alle das Problem
erkannt haben wenn sowohl die
Unionsfraktion als auch die Linke
Anträge zum Thema Waldbrände in
Deutschland anbringen scheint dies ein
wichtiges Thema als wichtiges Thema
angekommen zu sein den Jahren 2018 und
2019 insgesamt rund 5000 Hektar Wald in
Deutschland
wir alle sehen jedes Jahr was uns das
Bundesumweltamt anhand von Statistiken
für uns bereitstellt und festgestellt
hat nämlich die Waldbrandgefahr steigt
die Bundesanstalt für Landwirtschaft und
Ernährung verzeichnet für das Jahr 2021
bundesweit 548 Waldbrände mehr als die
Hälfte mit unbekannter Ursachen von März
bis Oktober brannte irgendwo in
Deutschland immer ein Stück weit die
Waldbrandgefahr besteht also nahezu
ganzjährig und kommen ein Bunde bekommen
ein Bundesland bleibt verschont
wir können auch feststellen ohne die
Amtshilfe des Bundes sind die schweren
Waldbrände nicht zu löschen Bundeswehr
und Bundespolizei haben im vergangenen
Jahr ein Nordrhein-Westfalen Brandenburg
und Sachsen geholfen Waldbrände zu
löschen bei jedem größeren Waldbrand
sind neben den Feuerwehren auch die
Helferinnen und Helfer des THW im
Einsatz
aber es reicht
sie sind eine notwendige Ergänzung des
Katastrophenschutz der Länder hinzu
kommen die Fähigkeiten von Bundespolizei
im Bundeswehr zwar waren die
Polizeihubschrauber des Landes NRW beim
Waldbrand im Sauerland im Sommer im
Einsatz aber es reicht offenbar nicht
aus der Katastrophenschutz in
Deutschland ist auf der Bundespolizei
und auf die Bundeswehr angewiesen die
Bundeswehr verfügt über 159 Hubschrauber
die für Löscharbeiten aus der Luft in
Frage kommen die Bundespolizei unterhält
fast 80 Hubschrauber allerdings ihre
Tragfähigkeit der leichten Transporter
ist sehr beschränkt
deshalb ist es ausdrücklich zu begrüßen
dass die Innenministerin Nancy Phaser
sehr frühzeitig in ihrer Amtszeit
entschieden hat die neu zu beschaffenden
44 Transporthubschrauber für die
Bundespolizei mit Winden für
Personenrettung und die
Aufnahmemöglichkeit für Löschwasser und
außenlastbehälter auszustatten der
Doppelnutzen ist offensichtlich sie
dienen der Aufgaben der Bundespolizei
und Sie können dem Notfall zur
Menschenrettung und für die
Brandbekämpfung von Wald und
wiesenbrennen eingesetzt werden
wichtig ist mir dass die Bundesregierung
in Zukunft eine Bereitschaft für den
Bevölkerungsschutz einrichtet die im
Rahmen der Amtshilfe des Bundes in der
Not sofort verfügbar ist zum Beispiel
zur Brandbekämpfung bei Waldbränden oder
bei flugkatastrophen wie im Ahrtal
diese tragöde darf uns nicht darf ich
nicht wiederholen die Fähigkeiten müssen
verfügbar sein und es muss klar sein wer
über ihrem Einsatz entscheidet
schließlich muss es ein schnelles
Entscheidungsverfahren geben in der Not
können wir nicht stundenlang warten bis
die Anträge einer Kommune über die
Bezirksregierung über die
Landesministerien zur Bundesregierung
und wieder zurückgelaufen ist also
nochmal ohne die Amtshilfe des Bundes
geht es nicht ein weiteres gutes
Beispiel für den Doppelnutzen sind die
Löschflugzeuge die die Bundesregierung
nun beschafft im Sommer brauchten wir
Löschflugzeuge aus Italien und hat zwei
Brände aus der Luft zu bekämpfen zu
können
die Europäische Union finanziert
Löschhubschrauber und Löschflugzeuge
über ihre katastrophenschutzverfahren
die bisherigen Innenminister haben sich
die bei diesem Programm nicht beteiligt
auch das hat unsere Innenminister Nancy
fazer
sorry
auch das hat unsere
zusammen mit dem Kollegen aus
Niedersachsen Boris Pistorius geändert
Deutschland wird
Deutschland wird sich EU-Programm mit
zwei Löschflugzeugen beteiligen das ist
gut für die europäische Solidarität und
es ist gut für unser Land wenn wieder
mal großflächige Gewalt Brände entstehen
der doppelten für unsere EU-Politik und
dem Bevölkerungsschutz liegt auf der
Hand sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
sind politisch verantwortlich dafür
bestmöglich vorzusorgen
wir sind auch verantwortlich dafür dass
viele tausend Helferinnen und Helfer in
den nächsten Notsituationen besser
ausgerüstet und vorbereitet sind und wir
sind verantwortlich dafür aus den
Fehlern der Vergangenheit zu lernen
Bevölkerungsschutz bedeutet dass wir uns
alle auf alle Eventualitäten bestmöglich
vorbereiten und das wird die
Ampel-Koalition auch in der nicht
polizeilichen Gefahrenabwehr leisten
in dem vergangenen zwei Jahren haben wir
kräftig in den Bevölkerungsschutz
investiert gemeinsam mit den Ländern
haben wir das gemeinsame
Kompetenzzentrum Bevölkerungsschutz
aufgebaut das gkopp ist die Keimzelle
dafür dass Bund und Länder in Zukunft
gemeinsam den Schutz der Bevölkerung
gewährleisten können das gkopp wird sich
in einem effizienten
Ressourcenmanagement beteiligen und
kümmern
und wenn ich von wir spreche da meine
ich Bund und Länder und wir haben eine
geteilte Kompetenz in den
Bevölkerungsschutz sowie ist das
Grundgesetz Bund und Länder sind beide
verantwortlich sie müssen ihre
Fähigkeiten bündeln auch um Kosten zu
teilen und zu verringern
und einem Beispiel Waldbrand können wir
beispielhaft zeigen wie gute Bevölkerung
wie gut Bevölkerungsschutz aussieht das
Szenario ist klar ein großer Brand der
von den Einsatzkräften der Feuerwehr
nicht in den Griff zu kriegen ist wir
definieren ein Schutzziel in diesem Fall
der Schutz von Menschen Umweltwirtschaft
und massiven Waldbränden
anhand des schutzziels und des Szenarios
bewerten wir die vorhandenen Fähigkeiten
wir sehen schnell dass wir
Schwachstellen haben zum Beispiel bei
Hubschraubern und löschzeugen aber auch
bei Vorsorge und Früherkennung mit
Drohnen und Länder ergänzen ihre
Ausstattung im gegenseitigen
Einvernehmen und die Menge schnell um
die Menge schnellstmöglich zu beenden zu
beheben soweit Mängel auch bei den
Zuständigkeit des meldewegen eine andere
Strukturen besteht werden auch diese
behoben werden am Ende steht der gute
Bevölkerungsschutz für das Szenario weit
waren sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die
ampelkonditionen Bevölkerungsschutz
gemeinsam mit dem willigen Bundesländern
wir haben die Zeiten werden in
Bevölkerungsschutz eingeleitet und
werden sie konsequent verwirklichen wir
übernehmen politische Verantwortung und
werden den Erwartungen der Menschen
gerecht vielen Dank
soweit die Verteidigung hier von Ingo
Schäfer er sitzt wie auch der nächste
Redner im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat und der nächste Steffen Jannik
für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren das Jahr 2022 hat uns Deutschen
schmerzhaft die Gefahr durch Waldbrände
vor Augen geführt im Harz in Brandenburg
sowie in meiner Heimat der Sächsischen
Schweiz kam es zu wochenlang im Renten
welche riesige Waldflächen
buchstäblichen Asche legten wir und ich
hoffe ich kann da im Namen aller
Abgeordneten in diesem Haus sprechen
danken allen Helfern für den Fleiß ihren
Mut und ihre unerschädlichen
Opferbereitschaft im Kampf gegen die
Flammen
und es ist deswegen erforderlich dass
wir die Themen Brandbekämpfung und
präventiven waldbrandschutz in den
Mittelpunkt drücken die
Kompetenzverteilung des Grundgesetzes
sieht jedoch für die allgemeine
Gefahrenabwehr grundsätzlich eine
Zuständigkeit der Länder vor hierzu
zählt auch der Brandschutz eine
ergänzende Ausstattung des Bundes im
Bereich des Brandschutzes kann den
Katastrophen Katastrophenschutz der
Länder nur ergänzen aber nicht ersetzen
die eine Nutzung der bundeseigenen
Fahrzeuge und Geräte im Bereich der
allgemeinen Gefahr Gefahrenabwehr also
unterhalb der Schwelle zur Katastrophe
sie das Gesetz bisher nicht vor sondern
wird vom Bund lediglich geduldet solange
sich an den
Zuständigkeitsverteilung zwischen
Katastrophenschutz und Zivilschutz im
Zusammenspiel mit den Ländern nichts
ändert ist es völlig unzweckmäßig den
Grund zum Hauptprotagonisten der
Waldbrandbekämpfung zu kümmern der
Antrag der CDU tut aber genau das ein
moderner Bevölkerungsschutz darf den
Katastrophenschutz und den Zivilschutz
nicht länger trennen beides ist eine
Einheit und die Parlamente müssen
hierfür die Grundlage schaffen
im Wortlaut ihres Antrages fordern sie
von der CDU die Bundesregierung auf das
Mindestmaß für vorsätzliche
Brandstiftung auf zwei Jahre zu erhöhen
die Strafbarkeit der Brandstiftung
ergibt sich jedoch aus dem
Strafgesetzbuch allein also einem
parlamentsgesetz des Bundes die CDU ist
in nunmehr 70 Jahren hier im Bundestag
vertreten offenbar müssen wir ihn von
der AFD noch erklären dass formelle
Gesetze grundgesetzkonform nur vom
Bundestag selbst und nicht von der
Regierung geändert werden können wenn es
ihnen mit der Forderung ernst ist legen
Sie doch bitte einen Gesetzesentwurf vor
zu
dem zu dem Antrag der Linken bleibt
festzustellen dass er ähnlich dem Antrag
von der CDU-Fraktion völlig außer Acht
lässt dass die Länder offene
Arbeitsgruppe nationaler waldbrandschutz
bereits verschiedene Konzepte zur
Brandbekämpfung erörtert hat die
fachlich zuständigen Experten haben sich
entgegen ihrer antragsforderung
einhelligt gegen den Einsatz von
Löschflugzeugen ausgesprochen dieser
Erkenntnis finden Sie nun auch nun mehr
im parlamentlichen Dokumentationen
dokumentations- und Informationssystem
wenn sie mit der gebotenen Sorgfalt zu
diesem Thema recherchieren diesen
Umstand können sie nicht einfach
ignorieren aber im Innenausschuss können
sie ja oder haben Sie die Möglichkeit
ihre Fehler im Änderungsantrag
auszubessern in dieser Form sind beide
Anträge leider nicht zustimmungsfähig
aber eines
aber eine Sache kann der Bund heute
schon tun meine Anfrage zu dieser
Thematik hat ergeben dass der Bund den
Ländern im Rahmen der ergänzenden
Ausstattung für den Katastrophenschutz
in den letzten 15 Jahren 592
Löschgruppenfahrzeug und 135
Schlauchwagen breit gestellt hat der
Stadtstaat Hamburg hat vom Bund mehr
katastrophenschutzfahrzeuge erhalten als
die waldreichen Flächenländer
Brandenburg Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Sachsen-Anhalt zusammen ich werde
hierfür dass der ergänzenden Ausstattung
des Bundes künftig die Verwandten
vorhandene Waldfläche der
Empfängerländer Stärke Berücksichtigung
findet das würde der
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit beim
Katastrophenschutz wesentlich mehr
entsprechen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Niklas wahrgenommen
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Folgen der
Klimakrise für den Wald sind auch in
diesem Jahr durch zahlreiche Waldbrände
wieder sehr deutlich geworden eine
Fläche von 660.000 Hektar Wald ist in
Europa in diesem Sommer verbrannt auch
in Deutschland musste eine nie
dagewesene Waldfläche dem Feuer weichen
zunächst möchte ich einen Einsatzkräften
von der Feuerwehr über Polizei und
Bundeswehr bis hin zu unseren
försterinnen und Förstern sehr für ihren
engagierten Einsatz auch in diesem
Sommer dank
erst
erst vergangene Woche war ich gemeinsam
mit meinem Kollegen Eckert
in Grunewald gemeinsam mit dem Berliner
Landeskommando der Bundeswehr der
Landespolizei in Berliner Forsten haben
wir uns über die Schäden des Waldbrandes
informiert und auch über Lehren aus
diesem Brand Ereignis gesprochen während
die genaue Brandursache auf dem
Sprengplatz im Grunewald noch von einer
fachgutachterin ermittelt wird steht sie
in zahlreichen anderen Fällen längst
fest Brandstiftungen eine unachtsame
Zigarette oder das im Wald geparkte Auto
mit heißem Motor zu banal es klingt aber
der beste Schutz gegen Waldbrände bleibt
Achtsamkeit im Wald und das Bewusstsein
in den Köpfen der Menschen das auf der
kleinste Funke ausreicht um einen
Flächenbrand zu verursachen
als ich kürzlich als ich kürzlich mit
dem renommierten Freiburger
feuerökologen Professor Goldammer
zusammensaß appellierte er nochmal an
mich dass wir 90 Prozent unserer
Anstrengungen in die Prävention
investieren müssen auch wenn der
durchaus richtige Ruf nach mehr
löschhubschraubern und Löschflugzeugen
auf den mein Kollege Eckert gleich noch
mal eingehen wird politisch greifbarer
und verlockender erscheint dürfen wir
nicht vergessen wo der eigentliche
Schwerpunkt unserer Politik liegen muss
in der Bekämpfung der Brandursachen als
Ampelkoalition stellen wir 900 Millionen
Euro für Klima angepasstes
weidmanagement zur Verfügung wer sein
weil so bewirtschaftet dass der
Waldumbau hin zu mehr Standort
heimischen Laubbäumen vorangetrieben
wird das entwässerungsstrukturen
zurückgebaut werden das Artenvielfalt im
Wald vorangetrieben wird erhält eine
Bundesförderung das ist denn es sind die
Kiefern Reinbestände die besonders gut
brennen die Natur näher und artenreicher
ein Wald bewir verhaftet wird umso
besser ist er für die Herausforderungen
der Klimakrise gewappnet wir müssen also
alle Anstrengungen investieren um den
Waldumbau in Deutschland zügig
voranzutreiben und dadurch aktive
waldbrandprävention zu betreiben
der beste waldbrandschutz bleibt am Ende
des Tages der Klimaschutz der nur auf
Hubschrauber setzt hat die Ursache nicht
verstanden wir tun also das eine ohne
das andere zu lassen herzlichen Dank
soweit in niklasse Wagner noch Student
der Forstwirtschaft hier im Plenum und
als nächstes spricht für die
Linksfraktion André Hahn die
Linksfraktion hat hier auch einen Antrag
eingereicht
fordert in ihrem Antrag durchaus viel
Richtiges das meiste ist also aus Sicht
der Linken im Prinzip unterstützenswert
und wir sollten darüber in der gebotenen
Gründlichkeit in den zuständigen
Fachausschüssen diskutieren was das
Löschen von brennenden aus der Luft
angeht bleibt der Antrag aber leider
viel zu taghaft sie beantragen lediglich
das Bund und Länder die Beschaffung von
löschhubschraubern und Flugzeugen prüfen
sollen auch auf der EU-Ebene sprechen
Sie beim rescu-mechanismus von aktive
Unterstützung ohne wirklich konkreter zu
werden das klingt für mich wenig
ambitioniert und setzt eigentlich nur
den Kurs fort der unionsgeführten
Innenministerium im zivilen
bevölkerungs- und Katastrophenschutz der
letzten Jahre bedauerlicherweise
Standard gewesen ist
als Abgeordneter aus der Sächsischen
Schweiz bin ich davon überzeugt die
Folgen solcher Zaghaftigkeit werden
Menschen schlimmstenfalls schon in der
nächsten Waldbrandsaison ausbaden müssen
deshalb müssen wir jetzt gegensteuern
dazu gehört auch die jahrelange
Diskussion über die Anschaffung von
Löschflugzeugen möglichst schnell zu
beenden und endlich Nägel mit Köpfen zu
machen also die für die Brandbekämpfung
erforderliche Technik vorzuhalten
denn der Bedarf ist zweifelsfrei da und
die Einsatzszenarien sind es auch in der
Sächsischen Schweiz wie auch am Brocken
und ich mag mir gar nicht ausmalen in
welchem Gebieten in Deutschland
vielleicht schon in naher Zukunft meine
Damen und Herren wir dürfen nicht
abwarten bis wir allein hier in
Deutschland mehr waldbrandeinsätze haben
als die vorhandenen EU weiten
Kapazitäten abdecken können der Betrieb
der löschflugzeug-
und da irritiert es denn schon das SPD
und Grüne sich laut Presseberichten
dieser Tage für eine aus eu-bundes und
Landesmitteln finanzierte
niedersächsische Einheit von
Löschflugzeugen einsetzen wollen wir
brauchen aber keine regionalen
Alleingänge sondern eine bundesweite
Lösung und ich hätte im übrigen einige
Ideen wo diese flugzeugstaffel auch in
Ostdeutschland einen geeigneten Standort
finden könnte
wenn Bundeskanzler Scholz im Rahmen der
sogenannten zeitenwände im militärischen
Bereich ein 100 Milliarden
aufrüstungspaket verkündet dann stellt
sich die Frage warum nicht auch im
Bereich des zivilen Katastrophenschutzes
eine halbwegs vergleichbares Engagement
gezeigt wird den bundesweit waren nun
ablaufenden Jahr wieder häufig die
überwiegend ehrenamtlichen
Feuerwehreinheiten gefordert ich will
auch für meine Fraktion an dieser Stelle
den Einsatzkräften für ihre
herausragendes Engagement noch einmal
ganz herzlich danken
aber wir als Parlament müssen dann auch
die dringend dafür Sorge tragen dass
ihnen auch wirksame und effektive
Einsatzmittel zur Verfügung stehen die
LINKE fordert deshalb in einem eigenen
Antrag die Bundesregierung dazu auf eine
brandbekämpfungseinheit aufzustellen die
bei Waldbränden in Deutschland und in
Europa zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann
dazu gehören unabdingbar auch
Löschflugzeugen kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss Frau Präsidenten die dann sowohl
national als auch bei Bedarf am
europäischen Bereich eingesetzt werden
diskutiert haben wir lange genug jetzt
gilt es zu handeln
jetzt gilt es zu handeln sagt André Hahn
das hat übrigens auch Sachsen-Anhalt
mitbekommen 2022 hat es dort deutlich
häufiger gebrannt als im Vorjahr und
deswegen wird auch der Forstminister
sachsen-anhaltsgleich sprechen wenn
Schulze nun erst einmal aber Sandra
bubendorfer Licht für die FDP-Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
ich habe in der Antrag aufmerksam
gelesen und ich muss sagen ich stimme
Ihnen in den meisten Punkten inhaltlich
auch zu aber dann komme ich zu dem Punkt
wo ich mich doch Frage wieso haben wir
in Deutschland nicht schon längst eine
umfassende
waldbrandprävention deshalb haben wir im
Jahr 2022 noch kein umfassendes
Monitoring in Sachen Waldbrände das und
endlich auch im Rahmen der
resilienstrategie der Fortschritt
Koalition aufgebaut wird warum berichten
mir bayerische Fall eines
flächendeckende Waldbrandes lieber nicht
da weil man das so schlecht aufgestellt
sei sie hatten 16 Jahre lang die
Verantwortung im Bundesinnenministerium
ebenso in den Ländern bereits im Jahre
2018 als wir einen der heißesten Sommer
seit Wetteraufzeichnung hatten haben wir
auf die Problematik und enorme Gefahr
von Waldbränden und durch die Perioden
hingewiesen als Antwort kamen dünne bis
keine Auskünfte nicht vorhandene Daten
und große Fragezeichen
lobende werden möchte ich jedoch ihre
Forderungen nach Drohnen und digitalen
Präventionsmaßnahmen der rennen Sie bei
uns offene Türen ein
und genau das gehen wir jetzt an was
alles hätten wir aber auch gerne schon
früher initiiert und auf dem Weg
gebracht gesehen deshalb war es richtig
dass wir uns als fortschrittskoalition
dem europäischen rescueprogramm noch
stärker verpflichtet haben aus diesem
Programm ruft nun das Bundesland
Niedersachsen zwei Löschflugzeuge also
stehen beschafft der Bund aktuell 44
neue Hubschrauber für die Bundespolizei
auch dieser Sommer hat gezeigt
Waldbrände und Ihre Perioden werden
aufgrund des Klimawandels stetig
zunehmen und wurde deutlich vor Augen
geführt wie viele Regionen mittlerweile
in Gefahr geraten
Waldbrandgebiet zu werden gut dass hier
die fortschrittskoalition unendlich
anpackt
im Rahmen der im Juli verabschiedeten
resilienzstrategie werden wir als Bund
unterstützend die Widerstandsfähigkeit
des Waldes bei der Bewirtschaftung und
den Umbau in den Blick nehmen
schadensdaten werden dabei
ebenenübergreifend und im Austausch mit
dem Wissenschaft aufbereitet ebenso
werden Erfahrungen und
bewältigungsmaßnahmen vergangene
Ereignisse ausgewertet und
Handlungsempfehlungen in Kooperation mit
der Forschung erstellt
wichtiger grundlegende Ansatz dabei die
implementieren einen Ressort und
ebenenübergreifenden Gesamtblick um den
dynamischen Anforderungen auch gerecht
zu werden
die fortschrittskoalition wirkt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir werden die
Kompetenzen und Kapazitäten des
Bundesamtes für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe auch bei Waldbränden
kontinuierlich ausbauen wir werden das
360 Grad Lagebild im gemeinsamen melde-
und Lagezentrum weiter ausbauen wir
werden den engen Austausch mit den
Ländern und den lagebildzentren vor Ort
ebenfalls investiert intensivieren sie
sehen wir packen an und das war auch in
Ihrem Sinne
lassen Sie mich Ihnen noch einen
Gedanken mitgeben sie legen in ihrem
Antrag den Fokus abschließend auf die
Erhöhung der Strafen bei fortsetzlicher
Brandstiftung bin ich vollkommen bei
ihnen aber ich bin der Ansicht dass wir
dort zunächst noch einmal die Menschen
dafür sensibilisieren müssen dass der
Faktor Mensch eben ein enorm großes
Gefahrenpotenzial bei Waldbränden
darstellt wir müssen doch den Fokus auf
Prävention und Vermeidung legen statt
auf Bestrafung nachdem ein Waldbrand
Natur Tier und Mensch gefährdet hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hatten wir gemeinsam im Bund in den
Ländern und den Kommunen an zum wohne in
der wunderbaren Landschaft unserer Natur
unser aller Sicherheit und ich freue
mich über die konstruktive Unterstützung
um Begleitung seitens der Union
gemeinsam packen wir das herzlichen Dank
so und jetzt von der Regierungsbank
haben wir auch ein Sprecher wie schon
angekündigt der Forstminister
Sachsen-Anhalt Sven Schulze hat jetzt
das Wort um hier noch mal
auseinandersicht die Situation zu
beschreiben
sehr geehrter frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Abgeordnete sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ich freue mich heute hier
auch als Vertreter der Länder sprechen
zu dürfen denn es ist schon ein Thema
was uns in den Ländern sehr ja auch
beschäftigt wir hatten im Harz dass
meine Heimat wo ich herkomme im diesem
Jahr zwei große Waldbrände und gerade
bei dem letzten war ich tagtäglich vor
Ort mit der Kollegin Heike Bremer der an
Wahlkreises dort ist und wir haben
einmal mehr gesehen mit wichtiges Thema
das ist deswegen vielen Dank dass Sie
heute darüber diskutieren wenn man sieht
dass wir allein in Sachsen-Anhalt in den
letzten drei Jahren über 500 Waldbrände
hatten nicht jeder dieser Waldbrände ist
in den Medien zu sehen aber trotzdem
zeigt es wie wichtig es ist auf dieses
Thema hinzuweisen Sachsen und
Brandenburg hat eine ähnliche Erfahrung
machen müssen also ein Thema für ganz
Deutschland wie wollen wir den Wald
zukünftig besser schützen
Zuständigkeiten wurden schon benannt
waldbrandpräventionsmaßnahmen
Zuständigkeit die Wald Besitzer die
privaten als auch der Staat
und da ist es umso wichtiger dass wir da
gemeinsam eng zusammenarbeiten im Harz
machen wir das ganz intensiv gerade der
Nationalpark mit mir als Land mit dem
Bürgermeister der Stadt Wernigerode mit
dem Landrat parteiübergreifend arbeiten
wir da intensiv zusammen das zeigt auch
geht sich darum aufeinander
einzuschlagen sondern geht es darum
einfach zu schauen wie können wir die
besten Lösungen suchen Waldbrand
Waldbrand Bekämpfung
Zuständigkeit Länder und Kommunen das
ist grundsätzlich richtig aber ich
möchte auch mal als zuständiger Minister
den Bund loben ganz explizit den Bund
für den Katastrophenschutz wir haben
Bundeswehr und Bundespolizei mit vor Ort
gehabt übrigens vermutlich dass die
Hubschrauber nicht in den letzten
Monaten angeschafft worden sondern
irgendwann in den letzten 16 Jahren wenn
er immer gesagt wird es wurde nur
gespart
und ich habe schon vernommen und das
wundert mich schon ein bisschen dass man
jetzt über Kürzungen im Haushalt für
zivil und Katastrophenschutz diskutiert
schauen sich an was im Harz los war dann
sollte auf keinen Fall gekürzt werden
ich möchte auch
das sage ich mal als als ehemaliger
Abgeordneter des Europäischen Parlaments
die Reste eu-staffel loben wir hatten
italienische Flugzeuge bei uns ohne
diese Flugzeuge hätten wir den Brand
nicht bekämpfen können und unsere
trauriger ist es dass eines dieser
Flugzeuge weniger Wochen später
abgestürzt ist die Mannschaft ums Leben
gekommen ist das hat uns sehr bedrückt
und deswegen gilt noch mal mein Dank
allen Kameradinnen und Kameraden die uns
in den letzten Jahren in ganz
Deutschland geholfen haben egal ob es
Feuerwehr war obs THW war die haben
vieles geleistet
ich komme aber auch als Ländervertreter
nicht ohne Forderungen können sich
vorstellen
wir müssen das Thema Kosten auch mal
diskutieren der letzte Brand im Harz hat
die hat den Landkreis eine Million Euro
pro Tag gekostet das überfordert einen
Landkreises überfordert jede Kommune das
überfordert irgendwann auch Länder und
ich will auch nicht dass man aus dem
Bundeshaushalt Gelder zur Verfügung
stellt aber ich will zumindest mal
anregen auch Richtung Bundesregierung
über einen nationalen Waldbrand von zu
diskutieren wo wir Gelder einstellen
könnten die dann in solchen Fällen auch
zur Verfügung stehen das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt wir werden in den
nächsten Jahren glaube ich da auch große
Herausforderung auf der Kostenseite
haben das muss weiter diskutiert werden
und ich finde es richtig und gut
schuld sein Minister erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen aus der FDP-Fraktion
nein ihre Redepause wird angehalten
zwei Minuten sogar zur Antwort
ich bitte kurz mal um Ruhe so dass wir
jetzt die Frage hören können so ja
vielen Dank dass Sie die Zwischenfrage
zulassen sie haben jetzt so ein bisschen
angefangen Forderungen Richtung Bund zu
zu berichten Frage an Sie wie weit sind
Sie in Ihren präventionsbestrebungen wie
viel Wasservorräte haben sie in der
Fläche das ist nämlich das Hauptproblem
dass diese ganzen reservas nicht da sind
und ich glaube daran müssen wir arbeiten
und das ist eindeutig länderaufgabe
zweite Teilfrage an sie sie haben sehr
viel Totholz auch im Wald rumstehen das
ist eine riesen Brandlast wie gehen Sie
damit um
tja da muss ich
Ihnen sagen es wäre schön gewesen wenn
Sie noch eine Minute gewartet hätten
hätte ich genau das Thema Totholz auch
eingegangen und
und auch und auch zu dem zu dem
wasserreservas das ist genau ein Punkt
den wir auch im Nationalpark Harz haben
und ich darf jetzt zwei Minuten
antworten
wir haben im Nationalpark Harz das ist
der einzige Nationalpark
länderübergreifend
Sachsen-Anhalt Niedersachsen in
gemeinschaftliches Projekt auch wenn man
den Brocken sieht das ist ja dieses
Symbol schlechthin für die deutsche
Teilung mit gewesen bei uns in der
Region und wir haben es über Jahre
hinweg im Nationalpark nicht hinbekommen
entsprechend Wasser zur Verfügung zu
stellen lag möglicherweise auch in der
zuständige Ministerin in Sachsen-Anhalt
Kollegin Frau dalbert von den Grünen war
da nicht immer die kooperativste das
muss man auch mal ehrlicherweise sagen
auch wenn es nicht jedem gefallen wird
das ist ein riesen Thema Punkt
angesprochen das ist unsere Aufgabe
müssen wir umsetzen machen wir auch bei
uns in Sachsen-Anhalt und das Thema
Totholz gehe ich gleich noch sehr
intensiv aber auch kurz und knapp ein
ich möchte noch mal Einsatz sagen
selbstverständlich zwei Minuten habe ich
noch ich habe gehört Reste eu-staffel
habe ich auch schon gesagt und ich freue
mich ganz ehrlich dass jetzt endlich
auch Deutschland sich beteiligen wird
aber ein Stück weit weg vom Jubel ich
habe das als eu-hauptmann die war mit
dabei auch erlebt wie ist denn war vor
einigen Jahren als Deutschland schon mal
hätte sich beteiligen können da hat man
in Brüssel gesagt das ist in deutschen
zu teuer und damals in der letzten
Legislatur weiß man auch wenn die
Verantwortung für Finanzen ja also bitte
einfach darum nicht immer zu sagen jetzt
funktioniert es damals nicht
funktioniert sollte man immer auch
Bedenken deshalb absolut
unterstützenswert das Thema Totholz
wir werden beispielsweise den gesamten
Nationalpark herzlich von Totholz
befreien können will niemand machen aber
es geht um ein ganz wichtiges Thema
Gebietsschutz das heißt an einzelnen
Stellen Totholz zu entnehmen
beispielsweise im Wohnbebauung zu
schützen um Brandschneisen zu schlagen
damit die Feuerwehrleute besser anbrannt
Herde kommen den Nationalpark Harz
entsprechend besser vorzubereiten falls
es wieder brennt genau das haben wir
jetzt gemacht insgesamt wenn es mal
hochrechnen 0,1% des Nationalparks will
ich von Totholz befreien auf dem Gebiet
von Sachsen-Anhalt und was passiert es
gibt einen Umweltverband der gerade
gegen klagt und sagt das darf so nicht
seine Sachen ganz ehrlich auch in
Richtung Umweltverbände das versteht von
den Menschen dort niemand mehr und das
hilft uns am Ende in der Debatte nicht
ich möchte einen ganz wichtiges Thema
war noch ansprechen
das erlaube ich mir jetzt auch frau
Präsidentin ich bin zwar hier für den
Bundesrat ich bin aber gleichzeitig auch
Vorsitzender der Agrarministerkonferenz
der Länder zumindest noch bis Ende
diesen Jahres und hier ist einfach die
Aufforderung ich habe als
agrarministerkonferenzvorsitzender eine
eigene Agrarministerkonferenz zum Thema
Wald ins Leben berufen und haben wir
viele dieser Themen diskutiert und wir
haben im September auf der
Agrarministerkonferenz von Cem Özdemir
gehört er wäre zukünftig bereit einmal
im Monat mit uns agrammen
auch zum Thema Wald lieber Kollege
Kellner wir kennen uns gut bitte mal die
Rückmeldung einstellen das ist
mittlerweile Ende November wir haben uns
noch nicht getroffen das heißt wenn man
uns zusagt einmal im Monat miteinander
zu reden auch zu solchen Themen sollte
man das auch einhalten wir brauchen als
Länder hier eine bessere
Diskussionskultur mit der
Bundesregierung das funktioniert noch
nicht vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit
ich habe meine Redezeit eingehalten
herzlichen Dank
der Forstminister Sachsen-Anhalt Sven
Schulze geht jetzt natürlich nicht
zurück zur Regierungsbank sondern zur
bundesratsbank hat ihr hier gesprochen
es ist ihm ein Anliegen nach Angaben des
landeszentrums gab es 80 Waldbrände in
Sachsen-Anhalt im ersten Halbjahr 2022
bereits sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Herr Schulze die nationale
Kraftanstrengung für einen besseren
waldbrandschutzes eine sehr wichtiges
Thema und gerade in meiner Region in
Niedersachsen denn der Harz hat in den
in diesem Jahr einen langanhaltenden
Waldbrand rund um den Brocken erfahren
im Nationalpark im Nachbarbundesland
Sachsen-Anhalt das ist eines meiner
beliebtesten Laufstrecken die ich im
Harz gerne Durchführung glauben Sie mir
ich habe diese enorme Schäden auch immer
noch vor Augen wenn ich 45 km entfernt
aus meinem Wohnzimmer fährt Fenster
Richtung südenschauer waren die auch
sparen deutlich zu erkennen das
bedrückte schon sehr gerade die jungen
nachwachsenden Pflanzen zwischen den
abgestorbenen Bäumen die schon durch
rotwildverbiss gefährdet waren fehlen
nun den Flammen zum Opfer das ist sehr
beklemmend Frau Wittmann in diesem Jahr
vieles in niedersächsischen Landesforst
und dem Auswahlkomitee schwer einen
geeigneten Weihnachtsbaum für den
Bundestag zu finden im Harz gibt es
nämlich nicht mehr die geeigneten
Fichten 25 Meter hoch ungefähr 60 Jahre
alt das ist in Borkenkäfer der
Trockenheit und der Stürme haben da
ihren Tribut gezeugt nun wurde sie aber
gefunden die Tanne aus dem Altenauer
kellerwasser und kann wie jedes Jahr vor
dem Westportal das Reichstagsgebäude
behindert werden und ich hoffe und ich
glaube auch meine Kolleginnen liebe
Frauke Heiligenstadt das ist auch im
nächsten Jahr möglich der Waldbrand im
Harz war nicht der einzige dieses Jahr
verehrte Damen und Herren auch im
Landkreis Gifhorn Gifhorn St einige
große Flächen Unterholz in Flammen und
erinnerten die Bürgerinnen und Bürger an
den heidebrand in den 70er Jahren und es
brannte in Brandenburg und in der
Sächsischen Schweiz das wurde hier schon
genannt und in vielen anderen Bereichen
auch und das verdeutlicht dass wir nicht
nur die Folgeschäden sondern auch die
Auslöser und die Ursache von Waldbrand
effektiv bekämpfen müssen nämlich den
Klimawandel und an dieser Stelle muss
ich Ihnen sagen dass die meine Damen und
Herren von der Union bei der
ursprungsbekämpfung in den letzten
Jahren leider nicht viel bewegt haben
denn waldbrandschutz beginnt nicht erst
wenn die Krise eingetreten ist die
Vorbereitung Bewältigung und
Nachbereitung muss gleichrangig in dem
Blick genommen werden Länder
übergreifend ich kann ihn aber
versichern dass wir andere Prioritäten
setzen in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
haben wir festgeschrieben dass wir
bundesweite präventionsbekämpfung
Strategien erarbeiten und die
waldbrandbekämpfungsmöglichkeiten am
Boden und in der Luft ausbauen weiter
Menschen werden wir eine bodenschonende
weitbearbeitung fördern wie zum Beispiel
mit dem 900 Millionen Euro durch das
Förderprogramm Klima angepasst das
weidmanagement mein Kollege Wagner hat
das gerade erwähnt klar ist dass wir
unser Land krisenfester machen müssen
und das machen wir indem wir insgesamt
etwa
639 Millionen Euro im Haushalt
2023 für Katastrophen zivile
Bevölkerungsschutz zur Verfügung stellen
über 36 Millionen investieren in die
Warnung von Bevölkerung außer durch den
stellen wir als Bund für die Beschaffung
weiterer Löschfahrzeuge für den
Katastrophen Katastrophenschutz in den
Ländern zusätzlich 5 Millionen Euro ein
die haben nicht gespart die nationale
Strategie zur Waldbrandbekämpfung muss
die Folgen des Klimawandels abwehren wir
müssen die nötige Technik einsetzen das
kann eben aus der Luft erfolgen oder mit
künstlicher Intelligenz ich selbst haben
wir die Brandbekämpfung vor Ort
angesehen und wir sind sehr dankbar für
die Italien der flugunterstützung die
zeigt dass wir in Europa gut
zusammenarbeiten und vernetzt sind auf
innenministerseite und auf kommunaler
Seite die beiden Landräte aus Goslar aus
dem Landkreis Hartstein Schulter an
Schulter und auch der niedersächsische
Innenminister mit Ihnen zusammen Herr
Schulze waren schnell vor Ort um die
Herausforderung anzugehen aber sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es gibt ihnen
nicht den nachhaltigkeitsbaum mischweit
das muss unser Konzept sein nicht zu
viele vertikale Schneisen im Wald ziehen
wiedervermessung und Biodiversität
das ist unser Weg und ich bitte keine
aufgeräumten Wälder dennoch müssen die
nötigen Sicherheitszonen im Brandfall
geschaffen werden Konzepte sind wie
gerade eben erfahrenen Arbeit Totholz
findet Feuchtigkeit und liefert Substrat
für den aufwuchs schützt den Boden vor
Sonneneinstrahlungen
die Insekten am Leben und Nebenfluss
Insekten sind insbesondere der große
Verlust am Boden Insekten
einen größeren Probleme Monokultur muss
der Vergangenheit haben gehören
nachhaltiger Waldbau und
umweltschonender Tourismus nimmt die
Bevölkerung mit zum Ende möchte ich kurz
von meiner Mutter sprechen die in ihren
jungen Jahren Krieg Flucht und
Verfolgung erlebt hat und im Landkreis
Wolfenbüttel in Dettum ihre Heimat
gefunden hat für alle Menschen die ihre
Heimat bei uns gefunden haben ist neben
dem nachhaltigen Umgang mit unserer
Umwelt vor allem Respekt Akzeptanz und
dass wir kommen sein wichtig frau
Präsidentin ich komme zum letzten Satz
das neue
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht ist der
entscheidende Schritt dahin und hilft
nicht nur bei der Frage zum Thema
Gewinnung sondern auch bei der Stärkung
des Ehrenamtes dem es an Nachwuchs fehlt
und meiner Mutter kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss jetzt alles liebe zum 85
geburtstag
ja hier gab es noch mal Glückwünsche zum
Geburtstag und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner in dieser Debatte das ist
Leon Eckhart für Bündnisse und sich die
Grünen im Deutschen Bundestag sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kollegen Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Deutschland ist Waldbrand das
zeigt die die letzte Waldbrandsaison wir
sind mitten im Klima in der Klimakrise
angekommen und ich glaube wir sind uns
einig mit den Antragstellern über die
zentrale Bedeutung unserer Wälder
alle Vorredner haben es auch gesagt
deswegen werde ich da sind viele gute
Sachen drin im Antrag auf die Punkte
eingehen ich glaube in wo wir in die
Diskussion gehen müssen um auch den
besten Weg zu finden das ist einmal die
Zuständigkeitsfrage Katastrophenschutz
Zivilschutz wir haben schon gesagt in
einem der Zivilschutz
Konzeption gehört kein Waldbrand weil
der Zivilschutz ist da wenn wir
angegriffen werden wenn Raketen fliegen
wenn wir unsere Bevölkerung schützen
müssen
Wälder sind da nachrangige Schutzziele
in so einer Ausnahmesituation deswegen
gehören in zivilschutzausrüstung
eigentlich keine vegetationsbrand das
muss man sich bewusst werden wenn man
Zivilschutz fordert dann wird man kein
vegetationskranken Bekämpfung bekommen
das ist Katastrophenschutz und
Katastrophenschutz ist reine Ländersache
und das sieht man auch im Antrag man
verwischt immer mal wieder die Spuren
was ist Zivilschutz was ist
Katastrophenschutz weil wir alle was
machen wollen und dann kommen wir eben
immer mal wieder in so ein Graubereich
und das sehen wir eben am Kopf gegen
Kopf sind die Länder freiwillig
versammelt und sich abzustimmen um sich
zu koordinieren
waldbrandkoordination man hat jetzt ein
einheitliches Einsatz Kontingent für
vegetationsband gebildet die Länder
Niedersachsen NRW Bayern drei von 16 ist
das unser Anspruch das drei von 16 das
ist was aus der Zusammenarbeit von Bund
und Ländern entsteht ich glaube nicht
und Sachsen-Anhalt ist leider aber da
kann ich das gleich als Appell mitgeben
ja noch nicht mal ständig vertreten im
g-kopf das wäre so eine bitte ich glaube
das geht Kopf wird dann stark wenn alle
16 Bundesländer auch dauerhaft da sind
und dann auch diese Energie zu
aktivieren wenn der Katastrophe ist
schnell Einheiten zu verlegen schnell
Nachforderungen zu geben und dann auch
solche Konzepte zu harmonisieren von den
einsatzkontingenten bis zur
dachkennzeichnung nur NRW hat eine
Regelung für dachkennzeichnung für
vegetationsbandeinheiten das wäre doch
ein Projekt wo man sich mal unter den 16
Bundesländern einig werden könnte machen
wir doch gemeinsam damit nicht jedes
Fahrzeug aus jedem Bundesland anders
gekennzeichnet ist
zweiter Punkt Löschflugzeuge
Löschflugzeuge helfen in manchen
Extremsituationen flächig hier Brände
sicher aber die sind nicht der
Heilsbringer die sind ein kleiner
Baustein ein Waldbrand ein
vegetationsband wird am Boden
entschieden mit unseren Bodentruppen und
das müssen die Kommunen und die Länder
schaffen unsere Feuerwehren umzurüsten
andere PSA geländegängige Fahrzeuge wir
brauchen Übungen und Konzepte auf
Landkreisebene um in die Fläche zu
kommen da sind ganz viele Landkreise
dabei aber da müssen manche Länder auch
Hausaufgaben machen Förderung
bayerisches Tanklöschfahrzeug 60.000 für
eine halbe Million Fahrzeug das wird
sich kaum ein Landkreis leisten können
und der dritte Punkt verschärfe von
Strafen da bin ich skeptisch weil viele
Brände eben unabsichtlich passieren ich
glaube viel mehr dass wir in die
Prävention geben müssen viel breitere
Kampagnen die weggeschnittene Kippe das
unachtsam abgestellte Fahrzeug damit
verhindern können wir haben viel zu tun
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam angehen
sagt Leon Eckert und das wird auch
gemeinsam angegangen werden zumindest
was die Bearbeitung dieser Anträge
angeht die werden nämlich in den
Innenausschuss erst einmal überwiesen
und dort dann weiter diskutiert